if you've been playing Rainbow six siege
for a while you might be in the mood for
something completely different
well I'm Tony and lucky for you this
GameSpot news update has just the thing
it's called outbreak and it's a special
co-op event that runs for March 6
through April 3rd we already knew that
but now we've seen the new mode in
action so what exactly has broken out a
bunch of aliens you've got breachers
that hit you with explosive yellow
bubbles reuters that pin you down with
spikes smashers that charge right into
you and apex that hang back and summon
more aliens into the fight you'll face
them on three different maps hospital
resort and junkyard and each one has its
own set of objectives think left for
dead but with CJ's unique brand of
shooting barricading and trap laying to
get you through it all new to siege in
general are the operators French and
finca both of which will be playable an
outbreak alongside a selection of other
operators ying buck smoke ash doc cap
can to chunka glass and recruit if all
of that has you excited I've got more
good news we've got plenty of gameplay
of the new event for you to watch right
now
[Music]
you